What's one reason you guys don't believe
in Islam?
>> One reason why I don't.
>> Both of you.
>> Okay. Well,
>> how about like Jesus is God's?
>> I got you. I got you.
>> A valid reason.
>> Sure. Sure. So, a big thing to me is
what the Quran says about the prior
scriptures. So, like, so for example,
we're in chapter 2. The Quran says over
and over and over again that it came
confirming the Torah and the Gospel,
right? So,
>> but the Bible, your the Bible now,
modern day Bible has been changed
multiple
>> time. I got you. So, let's let me go
with that. Okay. When would you say it
was changed? Maybe before Muhammad,
after Muhammad.
>> After Muhammad.
>> Okay. One, one quick. Okay. Can Allah
what can be changed? Can Allah what can
be changed?
>> No.
>> No. Okay. No.
>> All right. No. Okay. No. All right. So,
so the Torah and Tab and Jin is not
Allah word.
>> Huh?
>> It is. But earlier you
>> humans the hue of us
>> humans have changed the word of Allah or
they like the you know the languages
that these books have been brought down
with
>> are very like nuanced like you can't
>> but can they be changed can Allah's
words be changed?
>> No.
>> All right. So his point is is that since
Allah's words can't be changed the Torah
is Allah's words right the gospel is
Allah's words. So that means the Torah
and gospel can't be changed.
>> If you say they've been changed then
that would mean the Allah's wrong.
Right.
But so she's saying that well the Bible
which is the Torah, right? So the Torah
and the Gospel are books that have been
changed. Right.
>> So if they've been
>> so if they've been ch if the Torah and
Gospel have been changed that means that
the Quran is false cuz none of Allah's
words can be changed.
>> You get the point?
>> Yes. It hasn't been changed yet.
>> Very good. So if it hasn't been changed
then this is the problem. If the since
the Bible's preserved like the Quran
says it it should be then the Quran
would be all would still be false if it
contradicts it.
>> Okay, look here's the thing. We the
Bible was based on parts in the Bible.
>> It's just that over time it has changed
from the Bible itself. It has changed
over time like humans be adding some
>> Right. I I hear you. So Allah's words
have been changed over time. No, you
guys have when Islamic scholars when
they set out like a clear contradictions
>> within the book,
>> but like and then the
>> Christian scholars, they they don't know
how to respond. They just try to repeat
the same thing over and over cuz I I've
I've watched like debates between the
two religious religions and two
scholars, you know, debating it out.
Yeah. And all the time when when the
Islamic scholar says states out
contradiction, the the Christian
scholar, he's just like he's just like
like he repeats the same word. He just
starts stuttering, getting nervous.
>> If you haven't watched the right
debates, then
>> you know who?
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Oh yeah, I do. He runs from me,
>> brother. Look, let me show you
something.
>> He runs from you.
>> He runs from me. Yes. Oh, look. Look. He
doesn't believe me. Look, Shikman Uman
Iban Farooq. We call him Uran cuz he
runs from me. Watch. I'm going to show
you.
>> Yeah, we call him Uran.
>> That's That's messed up.
>> Yes, cuz Well, he calls me names before.
So, catch up. Let me show you. You
talking about this guy, right? Yeah.
Shake his mind. Right. Look, let me show
you.
>> You know, he wasn't he like Christian
before?
>> No, he was never Christian. No. So,
watch this. He invited me out to come
debate him in Las Vegas. I went to Las
Vegas to the mosque that he told me to
come. He said, "Come in at 7:00 p.m. I
showed up. He did not come out the
mosque to debate me like he said he
would." And he didn't let me in. He
said, "No, Nope. You can't you can't
bring your camera in or whatever. Let me
show you."
>> Well, well, he he's they were talking
about debaters.
>> Yeah. Don't watch cuz he'll he'll get
you lost.
>> I'm That's That's my thing. I'm going to
keep watching.
>> It's okay. It's you know, you can do
what you want, but we're just trying to
trying to let you know who this guy is.
Okay. Listen to this. Okay.
>> Tell us for the event tonight. If you
want to ask a question, he's doing Q&A
right now. If you want to ask a
question, you can come ask one question.
Just you no cameras or anything like
that. He told me a debate. These are the
rules for the Q&A. We can't just have
you know people doing the rules.
>> No, it's not the rules. Watch
>> come to the mosque at 7:00 p.m. and he
said nothing.
>> He did,
>> brother. The talk that you talk but you
don't walk the
>> Uhhuh.
>> tonight, Saturday night here in Vegas.
Same budget that you pulled back when
there was no dude.
See,
>> so he told me to come debate at 7:00
p.m. I come and he doesn't want to
debate.
>> Okay, he doesn't he allowed to come
there. He said
>> but he he has the camera on all the
time.
>> Okay.
>> So what does that tell you?
>> He's scared on his show.
>> But he's scared cuz he had a camera. He
had his own camera. Why didn't he let me
come in and bring the camera?
>> Cuz he was scared to debate. He had his
own camera. We could have both recorded.
He was scared to debate. That's what I'm
saying. Like shake of mine. talk to
Christians who don't know anything. But
when somebody like me shows up or
somebody like him shows up, he won't
talk to us because we'll embarrass him.
I already I debated him before. I
embarrassed him.
>> Oh, show me. Show me.
>> Oh, that's a whole It's a whole little
video, bro. Uh
>> show
this too long. Too long.
>> Look, look here. Yeah.
>> Show me to the part where you prove them
wrong.
>> Okay. So, look, cuz it's long. So,
>> the video like
>> Yeah, I'll show you the video. So, the
video This is the video right here. Uh,
let me go to if I go to my
>> What's your name, buddy?
>> Avery
Logic.
>> I'm Yeah, God Logic. That's what I'm
known as. So, this is U. Let me see.
Let's do popular. Let's see. Right. This
one right here. Uhoh. Is that dog? Oh,
no. That's somebody tripping.
>> See, he has a Jin, man.
You believe in him?
>> He got a I believe we believe we believe
in gins.
>> Oh, Lord. You didn't.
>> So this this is the video right here.
Okay.
>> Let let him sit for
>> those Tik Tok strings.
>> So look, it's Shakuz mom versus God
logic.
>> The video is why is Jesus the Messiah?
>> Okay, this video I embarrassed him. All
right, that was the start of it. I will
later like you got to you got to go
watch it. It's a long video. But but
look, so to answer your question on why
we reject why I reject Islam, okay, is
this problem right here is that the
Quran talks about how Allah's words
can't be changed, but Muslims tell us
that the Torah and Gospel have been
changed. And so
>> so that brings a problem.
>> You said, okay, as we said, uh Allah,
you can't change Allah's words,
>> right?
>> While in the Bible, it's been changed
multiple times. They're asking why you
believe in it.
>> Okay? So,
>> no, no, no. Because the Quran is the
only book that has been like the
language is Arab. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. It's like by
>> word for word, letter for letter.
>> Exactly.
>> No, that's not true.
>> Yes, it is.
>> Okay. Get get it for them if you can
find one.
>> Oh, yeah. We'll show you guys read
Arabic.
>> Oh, that's beautiful. Perfect. This will
this this will be good. So, um look, we
have these are two Qurans. Okay. This
one is the huffs. This one is the wash.
They're not the same. Okay. You you you
guys say you guys read Arabic, right? I
know we got to be quick. So,
>> no, not as good, but
>> not as good.
>> You can though.
>> She reads fluently. Okay, here. Do me
this favor.
>> Can you go to let's say for example, I
don't know. Uh, S.
Yeah. Chapter 3, verse 146. Sir, I imm
God.
>> Yes.
>> Is Jesus man?
>> He's both fully God and fully man. He's
God.
>> How come it says in the Bible?
>> Which one am I reading?
>> God can be man.
>> It doesn't say that.
>> Nor he nor man can be God.
>> It does.
>> It doesn't say in the Bible.
>> If I search it up and I'll prove it.
>> Verse one. Sorry. Verse 146.
>> Yeah. If if you show me the verse that I
I'll go with you.
>> Is not the same thing as
>> No, I I got you. I'm just talking about
that word. Not Not this one. This one.
>> So k that means to fight, right?
>> Can you help these kids?
>> You want to help these kids?
>> Excuse me. They're with their family. I
think we should leave them alone. It
means it means to fight, right? They
want to come.
>> What does fal mean?
>> Kart means to fight.
>> What does it mean?
>> To fight.
>> Yeah. To kill.
>> All right.
>> Yep.
>> Now.
>> Yeah. He fought.
>> Same same thing here. Go to the same go
to Sarah
>> chapter chapter 3 verse 146 again. It'll
be a different word.
>> It doesn't say what you said.
>> Exact same thing. Oh, it says that God
is not a man that he should lie, nor
send a man that he should change his
mind.
>> Um, the kat are the same words. Arabic
has it's the
>> this one this one means to kill. This
one is to fight. This one is to kill.
>> Guys, this you know what these are
called?
>> Yeah. Di critical marks.
>> Huh?
>> Di critical marks.
>> This is what is this called?
>> You're talking about that specific mark.
I don't know what this specific mark is
called.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Nice.
This is one.
>> This is the same word.
>> Where's Alif is here? Where's Alif here?
That's al the red one. Where is it?
>> What about it?
>> The alf is missing.
>> It's missing there.
>> And that's
what
>> um where's the word right here? Yeah,
>> that one and then this one. So this is
this is katala.
>> I'm going to say something.
That's that's either
>> these are two different
>> that either means it was it was a
man-made error. Somebody who like did
this.
>> Mhm.
>> No, it's not like a the word itself.
>> So which one would be the man-made
error?
>> Cuz it's not
>> it's the same word. It's just that
>> the diietritical mark changes the whole
word, right? Like the dama it that would
change it does cuz one means to fight
the other means to kill. Those are not
the same thing.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
>> So So you have and guys there's a bunch
of differences like this. We can show
you there's multiple different Qurans
out there.
>> Bible.
>> But but here's here's the difference.
Okay. The difference is is that we as
Christians, we don't claim that the
Quran I'm sorry, that the Bible is word
for word, letter for letter. Every
single Bible you go to is exactly the
same. You know, we we understand that
there's textual variances. Yes. Of
course, there's going to be textual
differences because these are ancient
texts. These are ancient manuscripts.
But same thing with the Quran. They
don't tell you this there. Even with the
Quran, it's ancient texts. There's going
to be differences within the
manuscripts. And that's okay because I
wouldn't say that this means that the
Islam is false, but you guys would say
that this would mean the Bible's false.
>> Okay? But little one word is your whole
scripture is like modified.
>> No, it's not. No, according to what?
See, look guys, this is what I'm saying.
Let me see if I give this to you. Let's
say Bible's corrupted. If the Bible's
corrupted, this is my problem. Because
the Quran says that it came confirming
the Bible. So if it confirms the Bible,
but the Bible's corrupted, then the
Quran is confirming. Wait, listen to
listen to this.
>> Okay, I got you.
>> Man-made errors.
>> Let me go with you. Let Let me go with
you. Man-made errors, right? Yes.
>> So let's say when man-made errors before
Muhammad came or after?
>> Wait, wait. Uh after
>> after. Of course.
>> Okay. So before Muhammad come, Bible is
still good. After Muhammad comes, Bible
ends up getting corrupted over time. Is
that what we're going with?
>> Okay. Wait, what?
>> All right. So, be before Muhammad
becomes a prophet,
>> the Bible is good and intact. It's
preserved. By the time Muhammad becomes
a prophet, the Bible's distorted.
>> When was the Bible found?
>> Huh?
>> When was the Bible founded?
>> That's over like 1500 years, brother.
You got the Torah, that's Moses, and all
them. Got the Old Testament prophets.
>> Is that before Muhammad after?
>> That's before. So, the Bible existed
before Muhammad. Okay. And so, that's
what Muhammad is talking about. The
Torah, the Gospel, the Psalms. These are
books that existed before the Quran that
the Quran is saying that Allah revealed.
You know, you know what I'm saying? So
then, so when Allah is in the Quran
saying he revealed these books, he and
he confirms these books, that means that
these books are true.
>> Yes.
>> Right. Now, if these books are
corrupted, then that would mean that the
Quran is making a mistake by confirming
these corrupted books.
>> Okay. No, hear me out.
>> Does that make sense?
>> If in the Quran, it says that it's
proven that the Bible is right. Yeah.
>> Um, you see like nowadays over time this
they add some new stuff. They change
some stuff in the Bible.
>> According to what?
>> According to according to the Bible
>> that's that's not true. So if if they're
adding stuff again this this doesn't fix
the problem. Let me let me grant you for
the sake of for the sake of argument.
Let me grant you the Bible is corrupted.
It's been added by to by men. This would
mean that the Quran is making a mistake
by confirming the Bible, saying the
Bible's true.
>> It's the same thing as saying right now
there could be somebody who has who like
has the Quran and they could change some
stuff in it. That doesn't mean we're
going to believe in that.
>> So, but here's the thing. The Quran
tells you to believe in the Bible.
>> Yes.
>> But you can't believe in part of it.
>> That's right. There are parts in the
Bible that
>> So, when Okay. So, so when did the
question is when did it get corrupted?
>> Uh over time.
>> What? Or like what over time? Like after
Muhammad's time. before Muhammad's time
>> before whoever changed whoever cut it.
So when was that?
>> Over time like we realized this noticed
it.
>> But so this is what I'm saying. Imagine
if I said yeah the you know I believe in
the original Quran before it got
corrupted. The Quran got corrupted
right. What would you say to me?
>> If I said the Quran got corrupted
>> over time.
>> I wouldn't believe it. If you
>> Why not?
>> Okay. Because I believe in the the book.
>> Yeah. But what would you would you would
you ask me to prove it? Would you ask
for evidence? Exactly. So I you would
ask more questions like where are you
getting this from? What's your evidence
of this? Right? So, like what I'm asking
you, okay, I'm asking you the same type
of question.
>> I had the resources
>> and if I was because we were just here
to walk around. I wasn't prepared
prepared for this. If I was, I can show.
>> Yeah. But there there is this is my
problem. There is nothing that tells you
that the Bible's corrupted. There's
textual variances. But if the Bible's
corrupted, then the Quran has a problem.
>> There is Okay, we're not
like directly stating that the Bible is
corrupted. There are just uh many clear
contradictions between
Yeah. So this would mean then that let's
let me grant you this again. So let's
say Bible is not corrupted but it has
contradictions.
>> That would mean that the Quran is
confirming a book full of
contradictions.
>> But can you show me?
>> Show you what
>> the like contradictions on the
>> contradictions in the Quran.
>> Yes.
>> Sure. Can I get that?
>> I show you already.
>> Well, but like
>> I know what he's going to bring up.
>> What do you think I'm going to bring up?
>> Nothing. Okay, look. Watch this. Okay,
I'll show you contradictions.
>> No, sir. Chapter 4. What's in chapter 4?
>> Sisa, what's what's in chapter n? What
is it?
>> N I want to use it.
>> No, no, no contradictions. People use it
when they like
>> Let's go.
>> No, I'm just looking for just going to
show them a contradiction. Not
necessarily a difference, but a
contradiction. All right. All right. So
this is Sarah Ysef.
>> Oh yes.
>> Okay. Chapter 111. I mean chapter 12
verse 111. Okay. This is chapter 12.
Sarah Ysef 111.
>> 111. Yep. There is in their stories
instruction for men endued with
understanding. It is not a tale invented
but a confirmation of what went. So it's
talking about the Quran. The Quran is
not a tale invented but a confirmation
of what was what went before
>> and a detailed exposition of all things.
>> So this is saying that the Quran is not
a lie.
>> Correct. It's saying it's not a lie.
>> It's a detailed
>> it's a detailed explanation of
everything.
>> It's a guide and mercy. Yep. Okay. So we
we're getting good qualities of the
Quran, right?
>> It's a confirmation of what came before.
It's a detailed explanation of all
things. It's a guide and a mercy for
believers. Right. Okay. So the part
we're going to focus on is where it says
that it's a detailed explanation of all
things.
>> I just want to say one thing like
translations like this and um English
translations a lot of them
>> like cuz this type of because how Arabic
is such like very nuanced like and we
all have different dialects. It's very
hard to like
>> get
Well, that's why we got the Arabic right
here.
>> Yeah. And we have another one right
>> Yeah. So it says the same thing,
>> but there's different dialects. Like
they don't speak
>> you know. It's like formal Arabic. It's
like formal uh rhino.
>> Uh
>> it's a type of Arabic.
>> Yeah. It's like
>> it's like like old English versus
>> Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. Makes sense. So
with that being said, so we have when
you look at all the Qurans, they're
going to all say the same thing here.
Okay. That it's a detailed explanation
of everything. It's a guide. It's a
mercy. It's a confirmation. Okay.
>> But by the way, use the fully
translation. Okay. So
>> it doesn't matter. That's
>> all right. So look, this is what I want
you to guys focus on. Okay. So it's a
detailed explanation of all things. Now
we're gonna go to surah Imran. All
right. Let me actually mark this.
>> I
>> seven.
>> Okay. So chapter three verse seven.
>> He is the one who has revealed to you,
oh prophet, the book of which some
verses are precise. They are the
foundation of the book while others are
elusive.
>> Uh-huh. So there are some verses in the
Quran that are precise. They're clear.
Those are the foundation of the book.
And then there are others that are in it
said elusive. This one says not entirely
clear. Right. So there are some verses
that are clear, some verses that are
unclear. Right.
>> That's according to this this book, this
Quran.
>> Yes.
Difficult to find or achieve. Yeah.
>> Yep. Yep. Difficult to understand and
it's not entirely clear. Right.
>> That doesn't here's the problem. The
other verse just said that the Quran is
a detailed explanation of everything.
Meaning everything is clear.
>> No. It says here in their stories
talking about prophet Ysef. There is a
true there's like
>> I mean but the surah is prophet Ysef so
it's the story of prophet
>> yeah but it's it's about a bunch of
things not just ysef
>> yes okay sure and then it says this
message cannot be a fabrication
fabrication means
>> rather it is a confirmation of previous
revelation confirmation of the bible of
the Torah of the other book
>> y
>> a detailed explanation of all things
>> boom
>> okay so what
>> so if it's a detailed explanation of all
things then it can't have things that
it's not detailed in
>> then say it's not detailed.
>> Yeah. If there's verses, if there are
verses that are not clear, then those
verses are not detailed, right?
>> They're not explained.
>> But it doesn't say that it's not
detailed.
>> It does. It says that they're
>> It's hard to catch.
>> Exactly. So, they're not explained.
>> Okay. Sure.
>> All right. So, if there's if the some
verses are not explained, but the other
verse says that everything is explained,
that's a contradiction. It can't be both
at the same time.
>> Make sense?
>> Anything is going to go against my
religion.
>> Say that again.
>> I'm not going to say anything.
>> Sure. But you But you understand though,
right? You understand the point?
>> I know.
>> She's silly.
>> China, you know.
>> Okay. Yeah. It's okay. But you guys
understand the point, right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, this is where uh one of the
contradictions is. Quran says it's a
detailed explanation of everything.
Another verse says that there's some
clear verses and then there's other
unclear verses. It can't be both at the
same time. It has to be one or the
other.
>> Make sense?
So the Quran says it's a detailed
explanation of everything. Okay? But
another verse in the Quran says that
there's some verses that are clear while
other verses are not clear. Not
detailed. So it can't have be both.
>> Not clear not can you go to not clear
not
it's the whole book. You're reading the
whole
>> Yeah. So so basically the Quran doesn't
give you everything. It doesn't give you
everything. Can you go to surah al surah
15 I and I are
>> what does that how does that help this
>> don't go
>> okay it doesn't help this
>> it talks about how Allah guards the
reminder right he sent down the reminder
and he's the guardian of it right
>> yeah I know the verse what does that
have to do with this go to 615
>> what does that got to do with this
>> okay just go
>> okay okay
>> no it's okay it's okay I'm going I'm
going all All right. 115, right?
>> Yes.
>> All right. It says
>> 115, right?
>> The word of your Lord, this is the verse
he brought up earlier. The word of your
Lord does find its fulfillment in truth
and justice. None can change his words.
>> There you go. Now, literally, it says
it's telling you that the word of Allah,
the Quran, is the truth. Nothing's
changed.
>> There you go.
>> So, look the problem.
>> So, okay. So, if I show you the same
thing in the Bible, will you believe it?
>> No. Cuz the Bible
>> Exactly. All right. Okay. So, the Quran
can make a claim and I can show you
there's different Qurans. So, it's been
modified. So, what?
>> So, what? That it claims that no one can
change it.
>> Okay. I see. I see where you're going
with
>> and I'm not wrong that you do like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, it just got to go. Y
>> like a place to go.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah.
>> Okay. If in the Quran, by the way, it
says, as you said, it says that Bible is
true.
>> It's true. Yeah.
>> Mhm.
Okay. If the girl was changed over time,
I would I would say the same thing I
just say to the white girl.
>> It's not what I believe.
>> So then what do you do with the with
what we just showed you? Remember we
showed you two different Qurans with two
different words. They say two different
things. One says that
>> because one was one was modern dialect.
>> No, it's not a different dialect.
>> We have different dialect,
>> brother. The the dialect would be the
same word. It would just be a different
way of saying the word like like water
versus water.
>> Same word. No, it's not. Katala and
coutila are two different words and
>> it means it both means killed. Uh like
>> Okay. Do you want me to show you an
example for like where where a word is
missing?
>> I want you to translate both like
>> Yeah. So to fight
to kill to be killed
>> that means like he killed him.
>> Yes.
>> No. No. No. Cutout means he killed him.
Katala is he fought.
>> Kata also means I I like
>> fought.
>> Okay.
>> I fought him.
>> No. Means I killed him. Yes,
>> that's
>> we speak Arabic.
>> Okay,
>> it's like saying for example like in the
Egyptian dialect when they say uh we say
me regular water
>> and and the country they say
>> but the same thing.
>> Okay, so this what I'm saying concept
and and there are in different dialects
like there's in English like the Bible
there's in Arabic there is in Arabic
there's in
>> I know I know what you mean. Have you
have you guys do do you guys listen to
uh listen to scholars?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Like so there Yeah. Shakes and
scholars, but I'm talking about the the
real scholars like Ibath, Alabari. Have
you heard of these guys yet?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Alabari
says is at the top when it comes to
commentary when it comes to taps.
Alabari even recognizes the difference.
He says that there's a difference here.
They don't mean the same thing. and that
there's a group that prefers uh one over
the other. If if they if there's not a
preference when you prefer something,
that means you're choosing one over the
other. That means there's a difference.
>> Okay, cool. So, even according to the
scholars, there's a diff these two words
are not the same. They're a difference.
Okay? The scholars say this. If you want
to look this up, look up Alabari on
chapter 3. Sir Imran chapter 3 verse
146. Alabari. Okay? So I'm I'm not like
just saying that I'm not stubborn like I
I looked into what even the scholars
say, you know,
>> so that so that matters. Yeah, of
course. Yeah. You know, got to got to do
our research if we're going to be out
here.
>> Like Christians as well, how we very
clearly we have similar concepts of
>> you guys are one and only of God, you
know.
>> Yeah.
>> And
you want the
>> but you know I cuz same concept of like
you know there's only one God. Yeah,
>> cuz you know how you believe in a three
way. I believe
>> I I believe in one God who exists as
three persons. That's what the trinity
is.
>> The Holy Ghost.
>> Yeah. The father, the son, and the holy
spirit.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> But how can God like Okay.
>> When you say how can God
>> how can God be human and be killed by
his own creation? And how can he
conquer?
>> Can you get the Bible? Man, that's a
good question.
>> Since S since you guys were dealing with
the Quran a lot, I'll answer some Bible
questions. That's fair. Thank you so
much.
>> That's fair. Okay. So, let me show you
what Jesus says cuz that's a good
question. How can if Jesus, you know, is
God, then how can God be killed by his
own creation? That would like be silly,
right? Yes.
>> Okay. So, this is what Jesus says. He
says something really deep, which is um
answer this directly. This will be in
John 10 verse 17.
You should have brought a sweater, dude.
>> That's okay.
>> I can give you my sweater if you want.
You want to go way up? You want a
sweater?
>> You want my hoodie?
>> Okay.
>> I have one in the car.
>> Way in the car, bro. You You going to
freeze when you get there, man. You
>> We can go buy you a sweater right now.
>> It's all good.
>> All right. You going to freeze, man.
Okay. So, John chapter 10. Oh, I'm in
17. Sorry. John chapter 10.
>> Goodness. What's wrong with me? My hands
are cold. All right. Verse number 17.
So, watch what Jesus says. He says,
"Therefore, my father loves me because I
lay down my life that I may take it up
again. No one takes it from me, but I
lay it down of myself. I have the power
to lay it down and I have the power to
take it up again. This command I
received from my father." So, what he's
saying is, "No one takes my life. I lay
my life down myself." So, they can't
kill him.
>> How is he talking to himself?
>> What do you mean? He's talking to his
disciples.
>> Okay. I have a question. Can you go to
John 2017?
>> Wait, wait. Before we get there, we got
to do it one at a time. Okay.
>> Say one at a time. One more time. You
know how it's saying, "Oh, I speak to my
oh father."
>> He says this, "My father loves me.
>> My father loves me." How can he like
when he's speaking to his disciples, is
he like speaking say, "Oh, my God loves
me." How is he speaking to himself? And
>> so, so, okay. So, the trinity is not
that the father and the son, they're
they're the same person. Okay. So
there's a difference between uh so with
when we're talking about the trinity,
we're talking about one being, one God
>> who exists as one being.
>> Yes.
>> Who exists as three persons. So the
problem that a lot of people have is
they mix person and being. So being is
what you are. Like for example, you are
a human being.
>> Yes.
>> Who you are though is you're one human
being with as one person. Yes.
>> Let's say for a rock, for example, a
rock is a being, right? Being is what
you are. The state of existence. A rock
is a being. Would we say that a rock is
per is a person?
>> Nope. Nope.
>> A rock isn't typically a being.
>> It is cuz it exists.
>> It's a material. Yeah.
>> Right. So that's the type of being it
is. It's a materialistic being.
>> A being like a living thing.
>> Nope.
>> Nope. A being is just a something that
exists. It's your state of state exist.
>> A rock is a being. It says a rock is not
a
>> rock. I don't care what that says. It's
not a living being. It's not it's not
alive. It's a it's an inanimate being.
You're
>> saying
a being is something that can reproduce,
metabolize, and
>> No, that's a that's a type of being.
That's a living being. That's an organic
being.
>> No way. If she searches up, what's the
meaning of being in a general sense?
>> So, yeah, a being in the general sense
is just something that exists, a state
of existence. Okay.
>> You don't have to search it.
>> No, she doesn't have to. What?
>> Huh?
>> No. A a being a being is is your state
of existence. sense.
>> That's what that's what being is.
>> No, I'm saying yes. Okay. Oh, okay.
>> Sure.
>> Trying to help you guys understand this.
>> In a general sense,
>> in a general scientific sense, a rock is
not considered a being or a living
entity because it's not.
>> See what it says that it's talking about
living entities. It's not a living
being.
>> In general,
>> science leans towards the idea that a
rock is not conscious in the way living
creatures are. The word of philosophy
keeps.
Look, so look, here's the definition of
being. One of the definitions is the
quality or state of having existence.
You understand?
>> So these are the things.
>> Okay. A being is an entity that exists.
Yes. Living creatures, humans, animals,
conscious
>> rock,
>> those are those are living beings. A
rock a rock has a state of existence.
It's just not animate.
>> If I told you like
>> why are we arguing about this?
>> Okay.
>> Like this is simple.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. uh state that's that's the
definition that's what the definition
is. It's a state of existence.
>> Okay.
>> Definition the quality or state of
having existence.
>> Okay.
>> It's just not a living being. It's an
inanimate being
and being of general sense.
>> Yes. So it's what a thing is. Okay. Now
uh so a rock is a being but it's not a
person. It doesn't have personhood. It
doesn't have a mind and will and stuff
like that. Right. Exactly. So there's a
difference between being and personhood.
Those are two different categories.
Okay. When we go to humans, for example,
you're a human being. That's what you
are.
>> Who you are is whoever you are. Don't
say your names, but that's who you are.
Right? Now, how many persons is each
human being?
>> One. Each human being has one person.
Now, let's go up even further. Let's go
to God. One divine being, one state of
existence.
>> How many persons? Christians say three.
Muslims say one. one. Yes, cuz
monotheism
>> well monotheism is just a belief in one
god.
>> Yes, of course between us there's no
like no one standing in our way between
our connection with God. Uh I would
argue that Muhammad is cuz the Quran the
Quran pointed to
>> but what I mean like for example cuz we
can't okay for example stated in the
Quran if God were to show himself the
universe can't it can't it's saying like
that's it like you know
>> yeah but he he does he
>> he does come he does he does come
>> what his his like his globe
>> wait I have a question
>> and it knocks out and it knocks out the
prophet Ma
>> yeah that's true so so he he comes in a
way where it's it knocks out Muhammad
and crushes the mountain but it doesn't
destroy the earth.
>> Um, oh yes. Yeah. Moses. Yeah. So, it
knocks out Moses.
>> Yes.
>> The mountain crumbles, but the earth
isn't destroyed. Right.
>> In a typical sense, cuz he can make
anything happen.
>> Exactly. So, he can come in a way that
doesn't destroy creation.
>> But how did he rise from hell? Like
because he conquered hell. They said
that he
>> he conquered death. He conquered death.
>> Death. He arose from
>> Yeah. So, what what that what Yeah. So
what that means is is that death because
so the death is the consequence of like
of like of of us. It's like it's a
separation from God. We it's the end of
life. Christ gives us eternal life. So
when so him conquering death means that
when we die, death isn't the end, but
there's life after with him.
>> After
so that's what that means. So yeah, so
Jesus says no one can take his life.
>> Yes, of course.
>> And he's the one who lays his life down
himself. So he shows that he has power
over life and death. He can come in the
flesh, give his life, and then raise it
back up again cuz he's God. Only God can
do that.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay. And you know, you know what
we believe about Jesus?
>> That he's a messenger who did miracles,
born of a virgin.
>> Person that was killed on the cross
>> was replaced.
>> That was that was a different person
that looked alike and they mistak him
for
>> I understand that Jesus was rose.
>> Yeah. He he was Allah rose him to
himself.
>> Okay. So that so that's how Christianity
started.
>> Allah started Christianity.
>> Okay.
>> By making everybody think Jesus was
crucified.
>> So then
>> he was crucified.
>> Of course Jesus
>> but that but that's uh that's not the
reason uh you know what I'm saying
>> the crucifixion was the beginning. Jesus
being crucified is the beginning of
Christianity. Allah is the one that made
it. It wasn't being that was just a part
of us. Wait, how come part of us? How
come
>> I know but that's but as a result a
religion called Christianity began
because they thought Jesus was crucified
and then they thought that they saw him
alive again and then boom for 600 years
before Muhammad
>> with us that it was it was it was he was
replaced.
>> No, I I don't agree.
>> You just said that.
>> No, no, I'm saying that I I I'm saying
that Yes. Yes. In your in your paradigm,
in your worldview, I know that you don't
believe Jesus was crucified. Yeah. But
but historically and biblically, yes, he
was he was crucified. Like what what
what would be the point of of Allah
making it look like it was Jesus
crucified and then not and then not
fixing that. So basically saying, okay,
for example, you said, oh, why did Allah
in his sense for Islamic perspective?
Why did he make it seem like um
Christianity was, you know, he created
Christianity?
>> Yeah.
>> As a test, same thing as he created, you
know, the devil. So, we failing this
big. We failing big time. Uh with me and
him, we're failing this test cuz we're
Christians.
>> But Allah made us Christians.
>> But in our test for you as well to see
if if you would like, you know,
>> No.
>> Mm- Free will.
>> No, brother. That's not what Islam
teaches.
>> Okay. Right now.
>> Free will. Of course.
>> No, no, no. Look, look. Right now, I
could do haram stuff, but that's up to
him.
>> No, it's not.
>> Yes, it is. Right now, if you want it to
make sense, right?
>> Can I show Can I show you guys that it's
not up to you?
>> What do you mean it's not up to us?
>> It makes sense, but because he has to
deal with that on day of judgment. God
will ask you questions. Is God forcing
you to
>> So, so two people are talking right now,
but I understand what both of you are
saying. So, look, here's the reality.
The reality is that yes, we do have free
will. Like, you can make a decision. You
can punch me in the face right now.
That'll be your choice. That's the
reality. We know that.
>> What I'm saying is is that Islam does
not teach that you have free will.
>> Yes, it does.
>> Can I show you?
>> As free will as a sense of a test. Okay.
Like,
>> no. No. free will like you whatever
decision
>> you believe that life is like a test for
>> I know but I'm saying that the decisions
you make the faith that you have is all
decided by Allah you didn't make the
choice that's what Islam teaches I'm
going to show you guys this okay
>> okay that's true but in a society
stuff that you don't you don't have to
choose like death
>> no like if you what you just said just
now Allah chose for you to say that you
didn't choose to say what you just said
that's what Islam teaches your works
your deeds your belief your faith
Like like when you say, "Oh, it's all
written and not." Okay. But when it's
written in your life, it's he already
knows what you're going to say. What
you're going to say on your own.
>> Uh-huh. There's there's a difference.
>> And it's and it's written on your notes.
>> So what you're talking about is for
fornowledge. I'm not talking about
Allah's fornowledge cuz yes, God knows
all things. He knows the future. He
knows what you're going to do before it
happens. All right. What I'm talking
about is I'm talking about uh
predestination meaning that or
determinism that Allah wrote a script
>> and you're a character that has to go
with the script like you can't go
outside the script.
>> Uh yes you could.
>> All right let me show you. Okay look dad
has control of things that
>> it's not whether like okay okay you know
that example you said oh we're not
talking about oh the for knowledge
right? Yeah.
>> He knows exactly what we're going to do,
how we're going to do before we even do
it from from as soon as he's writing me
down.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> For the whole script.
>> Yeah. So that's that's not him making
you do it. He just knows what you're
doing. Right.
>> He knows what you're going to do and
that path you're doing.
>> I got you.
>> He's already written it down.
>> I look I understand everything you're
saying. So what if what if it's not that
he knows what you're going to do, but
what if he makes you do it?
>> What if he decides what you do? Then
what?
>> Show me.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I got you. So, I'm
going to show you Adam first. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Look, watch this guys.
>> So, this is Sunnin Abu Daw. You guys are
all Sunni, right?
>> Okay. Good. You guys follow the suna?
Good. This is sah. It's great. Sah.
Okay. Yep. Sahin Abu Dau 4701. So, Abu
Herrera reported the messenger of Allah
uh saying Adam and Moses had held a
disputation. They were arguing. Moses
said, "Adam, you are our father. You
deprived us and caused us to come out
from paradise." Adam, you are Adam said,
"You are Moses. Allah chose you for his
speech and wrote the Torah for you with
his hand." Now, watch what he says. "Do
you blame me for doing a deed which
Allah had decreed that I should do 40
years before he created me?" So Adam got
the better of Moses in the argument
>> should and plus okay and also okay
hadith right
>> it's brother it's authentic
>> okay okay but look for example you know
um very famous
>> okay like that
>> the only hadith that is 100% correct is
from Muhammad Prophet Muhammad
>> okay
>> but hadiths like this cuz humans are
prone to mistakes
Okay.
>> And it's not always going to be 100%
correct because you know, humans make
mistakes.
>> But this is from Muhammad. This is what
Muhammad is saying.
>> No, but the hadith is who who written
it's not Muhammad. You said it's
>> No, look. Well, this is the where the
hadith is collected. But
>> who was the person that that like wrote
it?
>> I don't I don't know who wrote it.
>> Yeah. No, this is this is strong. It's
sah.
>> Yeah. It's authentic. It's strong. My my
point is guys is that according to the
what Muhammad is saying Muhammad said
this and he's saying that that what Adam
did when he disobeyed Allah by eating
the fruit that Allah made him do this.
He decreed that he would do this before
he was created 40 years before he was
created. So Adam didn't have a choice.
You get what I'm saying?
>> It's like
>> he didn't have a choice.
>> Explain it. But he's like have a choice.
So look, Adam, look, so Adam is he's
having an argument with Moses, right?
Moses is saying, "It's your fault that
we're out of paradise, right? It's your
fault." But then Adam's Adam refutes him
by saying, he says, "Do you blame me for
uh an action that Allah decreed that I
should do 40 years before I was
created?" And so then it says, "And Adam
got the better of Moses in that
argument. He knew what the devil was
going to do cuz when he told him kneel
to this prophet Adam that's why that's
whyl was created that's why he was he is
a disgrace you know
>> no you're missing it
>> I understand but it's written okay it's
not typically
>> Allah made him do it Allah decreed that
he would do this
>> it was written for him as a test to see
if he'll fall for the for the the
devil's um trap
>> see here's the thing if if it was
>> the devil was typically the one that
influenced him
>> I got you but if if it's a test like
think of it think about this If it's a
test, then Allah is not going to decree
for him to make it do an in action. To
decree means that he's like, "This is
what's going to happen. This is going to
be done." Right? So, you can't choose
anything outside of Allah's. If he
decrees it, you can't change. You can't
do anything about that.
>> He knows what you're going to do. That's
it. It's written.
>> Well, if he knows what you're going to
do, but does that mean he decrees it?
No. He just knows. Decreeing it is
determining what's going to happen. He
made it happen. If he if Allah decrees
it, he's the one who made it happen. You
get what I'm saying? Of course, but it's
all leaders in the same thing as saying
writing in a sense of he knows what he's
going to do. Like, okay, he knows you
won't go out of script. Why? Because you
already did that. You already basically
saying before I'm born,
>> already live my life.
>> So, but look, Adam, Adam is saying it's
not my fault.
>> Sorry.
>> You get what I'm saying? Yes.
>> In Islam, it's Yes. Allah is like he
knows he's written everything down.
>> But every time we sin, every time we do
something, we we're not it's like haram.
Like you can't blame everything on Allah
because we are our un
in Islam, you cannot blame anything on
because we
>> let's say let's say okay, I don't want
to go to work today. Allah made me not
go to work today. That's not that's not
what we're like.
>> Okay. So So answer me this then. Why is
it that Adam was correct? Cuz according
to Muhammad, he says Adam won the
argument against Moses when Adam said,
"Why do you blame me for an action that
Allah decreed for me to do?" Because
eating the fruit when he when he
disobeyed Allah and ate the fruit and
got cast out of paradise.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Him and Okay. Adam
>> So Adam is saying, "Don't blame me.
Allah made me do this."
>> Adam is also human and humans say those
type of stuff. You
>> But but Muhammad is saying he was right.
Muhammad says that he was right. Look,
>> who's who's the writer of this hadith?
>> I I don't know who the writer is
necessarily, but they're reporting that
it's Abu Abu Hur is the one reporting.
>> I want to see this in the Quran itself.
>> In the Quran?
>> Yes.
>> You're not Quran only.
>> You're you're a Sunni. You don't believe
You don't follow Quran alone.
>> Huh?
>> You said you wanted to see this in the
Quran. Not everything's in the Quran.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. So I we can go we get a lot of
doctrine of Islam decrees in Islam from
the hadith. Right? So this is why this
is this is why this is important.
>> Allah decreed for Adam to eat it. So we
are sent down here on earth.
>> Right? So it's not Adam's fault.
>> It's not Adam's fault.
>> So then why is why is Adam being
punished?
>> It's not a punishment.
>> He was no no there. Sorry. There's a
difference between punishment and test.
Like and in the Quran it says Allah does
not test or put a burden on us like more
than we can bear. And there's
differences between test and punishment.
Punishment is like you know you do
something and Allah
>> he he was living in paradise and then
and then got kicked out after he ate the
fruit
>> because Allah told him don't eat it. He
ate it.
>> So good good. So so his pun wait I'll
let you speak. But his punishment was
being removed out of paradise. Right.
>> Yes. So he was punished for an action
that was that it wasn't his fault. Allah
made him do it.
>> No, it wasn't that Allah. Did Allah tell
him to do that?
>> He decreed it for him.
>> He that's the type of thing he's people
say like he would say.
>> No,
>> right now I could say oh the reason
>> if if I robbed a bank, I can say Allah
decreed for me to do this, right? So
don't blame me. Don't put me in jail.
>> That's something a human can say but
it's not right.
>> So but Muhammad says it's right.
Muhammad look. So look here. I'll read
the the hadith again. Okay. Adam and
Moses held a disputation. So they're in
an argument. They're debating. Moses
said, "Adam, you are our father. You
deprived us and caused us to come out of
out from paradise." So Moses is blaming
Adam for being kicked out of paradise.
You paying attention?
>> Yeah.
>> You with me?
>> Okay. So he's blaming Adam. He says,
"It's your fault we're out of paradise."
Okay. So then watch this.
>> Adam responds. Adam said, "You are
Moses. Allah chose you for his speech
and wrote the Torah with his hand.
>> Do you blame me for doing a deed which
Allah had decreed that I should do 40
years before he created me? Not a
punishment.
>> It was no the deed of course he's
punished for the deed he did though. Now
now watch what Muhammad says. So he says
so Adam got the better of Moses in the
argument. So so Mo Muhammad is saying
Adam was right. He he won the argument.
So, so look, Moses is saying, "It's your
fault we're kicked out of paradise. It's
your fault." Adam is saying, "It's not
my fault. It's Allah's fault." He's the
one who decreed this. You can't blame me
for this. Allah made me do it.
>> And so saying to Adam, what was when
when Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that when he said that,
>> he's not he's not implying that what he
said is right. What? He So, Adam got the
better of Moses in the argument. It
means he won. He won the argument.
>> He won the argument. But, how can I say
this? Uh, I know what I'm trying to say
right now. It was written, okay, it was
already written for Adam to eat the
fruit. God already knows he was going to
eat it even if he told him not to.
>> There's there's a difference. Notice,
look, Adam is saying, "It's not my
fault."
>> Okay, God decreed it.
>> Okay. The same meaning what you think is
decreed, right? is the same meaning we
believe as in um
>> fornowledge I believe.
>> No, no, no. Those different foreign
knowledge and his decree are two
different things.
>> Okay. You get the way I'm trying to say
as in it's already written for you, you
know.
>> Yeah. You you you guys believe in
predestination.
>> So you believe that Allah pre
predetermines what happens.
>> You say it's impossible for you out of
script. Why? Because you've already
decided everything you're going to do.
You know, like for example, if I grew up
and I became a doctor or whatnot, you
know, and I don't know that till now
until I live my life. Sure.
>> God already knows that.
>> You know that's it. You will become a
doctor. Why? Because
>> he already knows your predestination.
>> So brothers, I trust I want you to know
that I understand what you're saying.
>> Yes, of course.
>> I understand everything you're saying.
>> Yes.
>> The problem is is this. This is is not
what the text is teaching. My my
contention is is that if this was the
case, then Adam would be wrong. It is
Adam's fault. Moses is right to blame
Adam for why they're out of paradise.
However, Muhammad says, "No, Adam was
right." That he when Adam says, "Why do
you blame me for a a deed that Allah
decreed for me before I was even
created?" Meaning, you can't blame Adam
for what he did. He's not to blame.
Allah's to blame cuz he's the one who
decreed it. You get what I'm saying?
>> That's like me saying, "I robbed a
bank." That's like me robbing a bank and
I get caught and someone's like, "Man,
you messed us up, man. We're we're in
trouble because of you robbed the bank."
And I say, "Why do you blame me for
robbing the bank? Allah decreed for me
to rob the bank 20 years before I was
created."
>> It's all okay. But look, okay, I
understand what you're trying to say.
You know, I do. But that same meaning
you're saying decree is the same meaning
we're saying predestination.
>> Yeah, I know.
>> We're just viewing it from different
perspectives.
>> But when you when you when you describe
what you mean by predestination, that's
not what predestination is. That's
that's just for knowledge.
Can we have like a little bit more
something?
>> Yeah.
>> Like tell us what you want to
>> tell us what you wanted to tell us
because right now
>> you guys got to go, right?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> It's okay. We could we could So this is
why I would encourage you guys to do.
Have you guys read the Bible yet?
>> Uh yeah. I' I've listened to like um
certain like um quotes by people like
you know how they have bracelets or they
they read Sure. Sure. Sure. One time I I
stayed with a group depending on the
Bible how they explaining this and this
and I was just quiet respectfully. I
didn't want to get into debate cuz I
wasn't knowledgeable.
>> Of course. Of course.
>> Even still now like I'm not enough
knowledge is you
>> but
>> yeah we're just talking like you know
we're just talking. It's all respect.
You know I respect Christians and I'm
sure you respect.
>> Yeah. I love you guys man. I love you
guys. So look this is what I would I
would encourage you guys to try to read
the gospel. Okay. Like for yourself you
know you studied on the
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. So, look, I go
live on my YouTube. I go live every
Monday, Wednesday, and Friday. You guys
live out here?
>> Uh, around here. Yeah.
>> Okay, good. So, we're on the We're on
the same time. Uh, so I because I live
in Vegas. I go live at 2 p.m. Every
Monday, Wednesday, Friday. Watch my
streams. You guys
>> What time though?
>> 2 p.m.
>> I think I think I've actually seen Yeah.
>> Yes, I have. Yeah, you probably seen me
on YouTube during Ramadan. I was
watching like um Islamic scholars. So,
that I wanted to learn more. It's that
time of month. And I've I've seen
someone actually name God Logic. Hey,
it's nice to meet you guys right now. I
was like I was like God logic. I was
like I was like for a second from the
name I thought it was Muslim obviously
because God, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I pressed on and it was like a
debate um you know you're um trying to
uh teach uh Christianity like preach it.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So I was like oh
>> you know this is cuz I didn't watch it.
>> I'm let's be I'm going to be honest
though.
>> Yeah. No, that's good.
>> But I just remembered I was like I know
God likes like that
>> for sure. So look, so I wanted to tell
you guys about the live stream
>> cuz I don't want this to be the last
time we talk. So if you guys ever want
to join the live stream and just and
just chop it up, ask more questions, you
guys could join anytime. Okay. Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, 2 p.m.
>> Do you want like a name? Not like a real
name, but like a name like that you
>> you could just say, "Hey, it's me from
Santa Monica."
>> You remember?
>> Yeah, I remember.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Okay. It was nice to
meet you. My real name is Avery, guys.
>> It was very nice talking to you guys.
>> Don't you mind asking what uh what a
YouTube channel or Guy Logic. Yeah, he
has it.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we're
>> I was like I just remembered out of
nowhere. I was like I think I know who.
>> Yeah. So you guys Yeah. Yeah. Remember
cuz we're growing, man.
>> Uh in a couple years we'll be at a
million followers probably. Probably by
the end of next year. Yeah. So uh I want
you guys to witness it. That would be
cool.
>> Yeah, that would be cool.
>> Yeah. But yeah, get get warm, man. Get
your sweater, dude. You about to be
sick, man. You about to make me mad.
>> Hopefully we talk again.
>> Yeah. Hopefully we talk again. You guys
are smart and you guys gave us better
conversations than most people older
than you, which is crazy cuz you guys
were able to do this without being
getting emotional and offended. Other
people are sensitive.
>> It's always like, you know,
>> we're always open to listen.
>> It's always about ego
>> when their ego gets hurt, you know, cuz
always at the end of the day like
scholar and scholar, they might not
believe at each other at the end of the
day, but they enjoy the debate.
>> Someone knowledgeable enough to go, "So,
you know, I really respect this cuz you
weren't like saying
>> you weren't like cutting us over,
letting us speak, pulling up um you
know, your evidence, letting us pulling
up our evidence. It was nice. Thank you
so much.
>> Absolutely. I I want to talk to you guys
more about Jesus being God, too, next
time.
>> Yeah, of course. No problem.
>> Hey, we'll call in. Don't worry.
>> Yeah. Call in the live.
>> You're going have your Bible verses
ready.
>> You going You going to come cook me,
man?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm going make sure I'm ready there. Sh.
So nice to meet you, man.
>> Yeah. You, too. Take care, guys.
>> Have a nice
>> God bless, man. God bless. Thank you for
your time.